Hey, this is who I really am.
Sorry, you got the wrong guy.
You think you can fool me
by turning into an ugly dude?
I'm really not Mad Bark!
Why won't you believe me?
Super Invisibility!
Why did he disappear? Invisibility?
How can I let him get away?
How would I explain it to my master?
There's no invisibility.
This trick works every time.
When she walks away, I will...
You again?
What do you want?
Hell, no!
It's rude to defecate in public places.
You're quite tricky for a mutt.
Almost had me fooled.
I'm half of a durian.
I already transformed
into so many things for you.
Why won't you just believe
that I'm not Mad Bark?
Wait, I have something to say.
Actually, I...
Wow, pretty girl!
I don't care if you're Mad Bark now.
You're going to die.
I'm Killer Seven.
I'm No. 17,369 on the killer ranking list.
My specialty is to cut see-through bangs.
My constant quality service
and affordable prices
have always been popular
among the villagers.
My current relationship status is single.
Let's get a drink
and share our experiences as killers...
I just remembered that
I must go take care of something.
Peace out! The next tea is on me.
Don't forget to call me!